so first i want to go back to uh texas
governor greg abbott who obviously is
right in the middle of this thing right
now he is the governor of the state that
is thought of when you think about guns
in america you think about texas more
than anything else and this this
horrific i don't even want to say
tragedy this horrific murder it's not a
tragedy a tragedy is somewhat accidental
this is an intentional
horrific murder mass murder by this uh
18 year old
is happening in a happened in a city in
his state so to bring this thing full
circle what are some of the answers well
i thought greg abbott did a pretty nice
job right here
and i know people like to try to
oversimplify
this
let's talk about some real facts and and
that is
there are quote
real
gun laws
in chicago
there are quote real
gun laws in new york
there are real gun laws in california
i hate to say this but there are more
people who were shot every weekend
in chicago
than there are
in schools in texas
and we need to realize that that people
who think that well maybe we just
implement
tougher gun laws
it's going to solve it
chicago and l.a and new york
disprove that thesis
and so if you're looking for a real
solution
chicago teaches
that what you're talking about
it's not a real solution
our job
is to come up with real solutions that
we can implement
okay
so that's honest that's real
right the places with more stringent gun
laws have more
gun
deaths
someone explained chicago to me if you
are watching this and you think i'm a
bad dude and i'm mean and i'm lying
about any of this stuff and you want to
explain to me what's going on in chicago
which has the strictest
gun laws in the nation
as a city in illinois
uh again 46 people were shot this past
weekend that's a couple days ago six
fatally doesn't make the news doesn't
make the news and you have to think
about why and as abbott is rightly
saying as i've said repeatedly
throughout this
if you just had more laws none of this
would happen if we just took away more
guns none of this would happen yeah
you're right in chicago they could take
more guns away and guess what all the
bad guys would have the guns all the bad
guys would have the gun so i thought a
nice way to sort of recap this whole
show
uh would also be to give you some
specific numbers about guns from pew
okay so pew polling pew research
they're reputable i very few people i
think are doubting whether pew is doing
a good job or not when it comes to
giving us some sensible honest numbers
so this is an important part of the show
so when you're debating with someone and
they're telling you
all of this stuff and all of the deaths
and all of the confusion about all of
this you'll have some actual numbers to
go to so here's some direct data from
pew research in 2020 54
of all gun related deaths in the u.s
were suicides while 43 were murders
according to the cdc now just sit with
that for just a second
more than half of the gun deaths were
suicides okay so then you have to sort
of remove them from this mass shooting
conversation okay now again that's
clearly more of a mental health
issue than anything else but let's go
back the gun violence archive an online
database of gun violence incidents in
the united states defines mass shootings
as incidents
incidents in which four or more people
are shot even if no one was killed again
excluding the shooters
using this definition
513 people died in these incidents in
2020 regardless of the definition being
used fatalities in mass shooting
incidents in the u.s account for a small
fraction of all gun murders that
occurred nationwide each year in 2020
handguns were involved in 59
of the 13 620 u.s gun murders and
non-negligent manslaughters for which
data is available according to the fbi
rifles the category that includes guns
sometimes referred to as assault weapons
were involved in just three percent of
firearm murders that's a key part of
this whole thing shotguns were involved
in one percent the remainder of gun
homicides and non-negligent
manslaughters 36 percent involved other
kinds of firearms or those
classified as type not stated okay so do
you understand this a huge percentage
over half of the gun deaths are suicides
okay so that clearly is a mental health
issue and how these people are getting
guns we can discuss that okay fine right
and there's no perfect system so even if
you have mental health background checks
because you have background checks
everywhere every state has them
including texas are there some people
that are going to slip through the
cracks are there some people who are
going to be able to answer questions and
have a clean background check and and uh
fake it and then actually they turn out
to have mental health issues
of course there are are there people who
are going to develop mental health
issues after they have the gun of course
so again this is one of those things we
are imperfect we cannot create perfect
systems um but the rest of the that
information that i just laid out there
is pretty fascinating three percent um
were assault weapons but they're really
going after the assault weapons right
now now again we can have some
conversation about that we really can
and you know there's always this thing
well you don't need an assault weapon to
shoot a deer that's true you don't
um
we can have some conversation about that
but the implication is that somehow
we're having mass mass shootings and
it's all being done with these things
and it's a small percentage of the
murders with guns and
it's a small percentage using those
weapons in the first place